the jurogan experience
how often are you uh doing these free
solo climbs
uh you know i'm i'm working on things
yeah like
fairly frequently i don't know i was
just on this expedition uh
in the jungle in guyana it was like a
national geographic tv show thing
and i free sold the wall we put up just
just because the type of rock we're on
no one's ever soloed a wall like that
before so
i felt like since we were there's felt
almost an obligation to do it just for
like
this climbing history you know you're
like oh if you're there and you have the
opportunity you kind of have to
now when you see something like that do
you make a route first with ropes always
yeah yeah so our i mean because we were
there i mean it's a whole like
complicated natural graphic tv
thing so we were there with we're like
studying these endemic species of the
tapui's there's like this whole
interesting natural history component to
it
or sort of biology component but um but
we were just trying to climb this
mountain that had never been climbed
before so the priority is obviously just
to get up it to like find these species
of frogs to like do all the things that
are important for the tv show
but then but then because i was there i
was like oh you know on the side i can
at least do something that i'm proud of
and climbing that's also pretty cool
oh wow that's pretty cool yeah so it's
like this
like pretty and it wound up being
totally insane climbing like really cool
like this overhanging wall of 6 700 feet
high
you know like dangling it's it was kind
of the best style of
of climbing to solo because it felt
secure like it's the type of climbing
where you feel safe like it's very very
good rock so anything you hold on to you
know is solid and it's not going to
break
and it also lends itself to these sort
of striations in the rock where you can
like
wedge your hand in and like feel really
secure but
also it's incredible exposure because
it's really steep like because you're in
the jungle you can only climb stuff
that's overhanging because anything
that's like
less anything else accumulates like
water and dirt and winds with plants all
over it
so like the only stuff that's really
climbable is the stuff that is sheltered
from the rain so it doesn't have plants
on it
so so it's difficult just by nature yeah
so it's difficult because you're hanging
and so you're like in these crazy
positions where you're dangling from
your arms but you feel safe doing it
because the rocks so good and the holes
are so good and you're just like what a
crazy place
it's really cool but then when you get
to the the very edge you have to somehow
make it
away and that's a bummer yeah that seems
like the most gnarly part of it is
actually probably in terms of risk it
probably was the final 20 or 30 feet of
like getting onto the top it's all like
rotten soil and those rocks and like
you know yeah it wasn't ideal but how do
you decide which way to go
when you get to something like that just
what's the most likely
path to success yeah well so in that
particular case um
we had already established the route you
know like because it was this tv thing
we'd already climbed it we'd put ropes
up but we'd like worked on the camera
guys had gone up and down we'd like
camped up on this ledge to look for
these frogs
uh we'd like done this whole experience
so for the free solo i already had a
pretty good sense of like how i should
tackle
that part because you know we'd already
been sort of living up there a bit but
wow yeah but i'm like
what'd you do in february you know like
that that was my february
so these frogs like the the idea is to
is it really an excuse to climb or is it
like do you really
are you really there for the frogs to
check out these weird species
it's a little bit of both yeah well i'm
like i know this is a long-form show do
you want to like
go deep into it because it's actually
really interesting so
um all right long form so so okay the
trip was the trip is crazy i mean
we just talked about the whole time uh
i've read freaking eight books while we
were there because it's the jungle
and you know it's the tropics so it's
dark from six to six every day it's like
12
hours of dark and uh we're in our own
little hammock so i was just in my
cocoon like reading books every day and
so like a headlamp
yeah yeah but headlamp um because you
have nothing else to do it's like
raining and you're just in your own
little like personal cocoon just like
reading but um so i read like natural
history of guyana natural history like
you know sort of the the the geology
so um like have you seen the the movie
up
like the pixar disney movie the cute
thing with the flying house and the
balloons yeah yeah so you know that's
all modeled on
like where they fly to the big rock
things with the waterfalls those are
tapui's which are like real things in
south america
that's in venezuela guyana in the
northern part of brazil
or if you've seen the new point break
they film down there on the same
rock features i didn't see that but so
you're not missing anything no
it's really bad but uh but a lot of my
friends worked on it so it's like it's
cool and it is
like an incredible climbing place i had
a responsibility for patrick swayze i
just said
yeah exactly yeah you didn't miss
anything i actually fell asleep watching
it on a plane
when you fall asleep during an action
movie you're kind of like come on yeah
you know
but um but the climbing edge is cool and
and anyway so it's on these things
called the pooys which are like these
big quartzitic sandstone
walls that stick out of the jungle and
so if you imagine
a huge raised area of land
that because it's in the jungle has been
massively eroded by the constant rain
over the last 40 million years
so now you wind up with all these like
slender sort of towers and mesas
you know so like do you know angel falls
like no it's one of the biggest
waterfalls in the world here like pull
up a picture angel falls is a
it's like oh yeah yeah there we go
that's a that's a rhyme
that's you know what we're doing
yeah that's so beautiful so if if it
looks fake
yeah it does look fake isn't that crazy
i'm pretty sure that one is a rhyme and
if you
look to the left of the one you were
just on that we climbed this little wall
to the left of it can you go back to
that one jamie because
like if i was a dumb yeah so so that
would think someone built that
totally so if you could pan that photo
to the left though obviously you can't
because not in the frame we climb this
little mountain to the left
and so this is a really famous peak
because the summit of it marks the
boundary between
brazil venezuela and guyana it's used as
like the marker to separate those three
countries
and so we were climbing this sort of
little bastard step brother next to it
but with you know that peak though had
never been climbed and was like new to
science for the
different species of frogs and all that
kind of stuff if you're an explorer and
you've stumbled upon that you would
think that that was like a structure
yeah like it's so square and flawed and
some of them did like european explorers
that first came into the region
had all kinds of names like the white
cathedral and things like that like that
tower um
they're just a bunch of wow look at that
one click on the one your cursor is on
jamie
that's so oh actually so again so
actually you see on the left side of
that there's like the hint of a little
thing in the distance that
i'm pretty sure that's the thing we were
climbing the thing to the left that's
like just starting to appear out of the
clouds
yeah i'm pretty sure that's the peak
that we found god it's so beautiful
yeah yeah it's crazy except to be fair
the sun only comes out like so we were
there in the dry season
and it rained like eight hours a day and
we were in the clouds non-stop it was
totally grim
and that's the dry season yeah and so
you see these pictures where you're like
it's so beautiful and you're like yeah
for 30 minutes a day you know and the
rest of the time you're just
in the in the water yeah getting worse
that's so wild man
like really if i stumbled upon that i
would think someone built that
yeah no it's it's totally incredible
what is the g so i didn't i didn't even
get to the cool part of this oh it was
so
yeah asking about the geology yeah like
how does something like that form it's
so strange
yeah so uh that's the stuff i was
reading while we there so it's like this
huge
bed of sandstone which then gets
metamorphosed like compressed into
quartzite so like really really hard
sandstone
and then you know the andes so you have
gondwana like one of the mega continents
that predates pangaea i think
like yeah so like you know if you
imagine all the continents on earth were
once sort of combined
so south america and africa you know fit
together at the the horn
um and so this rock is
most similar to rock and parts of africa
actually
and so and part of what makes the the
biology that are so interesting is that
the creatures on the summit of some of
the tapuis are more closely related to
creatures in africa than they are to the
ones in the jungle below them
because because the summits have been
separated for so long
you see what i'm saying like because the
top of that those islands basically
they've been separated from the jungle
below for so long that they more closely
resemble where they came from in africa
than
than the creatures that live in the rain
forest below it's like this totally
incredible
you know i mean it's just it's just an
interesting part of earth
are you aware of the olmecs do you know
what the olmec civilization was
no the ole mix of it's really it's a
quite a mystery they don't exactly
know what they did or you know what
what their culture was all about but
they had these
heads that they left behind these
sculpted
gigantic stone heads that resemble
resemble african people that's not the
easter island stuff
no no that's different it's different
this is the olmecs
oh wow where and where were the olympics
in south america
oh yeah it says olmec yes south america
mexico central america
and there's a lot of them and these
images
are very um african-looking faces
and they don't really know what the
history of them wore
and they know they they think some of
them existed
in the neighborhood of 6 000 years ago
but you know when when you're when
you're looking at
stone it's hard because they they just
they carbon date the stuff that's around
the stone as they unearth it
but that doesn't really necessarily give
them an
accurate sense of when it was
constructed it just gives an accurate
sense of how
the sediment yeah of where it's around
so
the stuff in guyana though is um
on totally different scale like the the
stuff that i'm talking about the
i think the depuys have been uh eroded
away like isolated for 40 million years
or something
which you know far predates humans and
then i think the
rock itself is like 1.5 billion years
old it's like
ancient ancient it's incredible rock
it's really cool it's just so wild
the way it formed the the look yeah it's
funny because
i mean you saw the posters it looks like
islands and you know early explorers
thought that they must be islands or
something but it's actually
uh just the eroded remnants of what was
once like a giant
you know elevated plateau oh yeah
totally so this is what the summits look
like
i have a bunch of photos like that on my
phone it's just like scrappy little
iphone pics of uh like here we are on
this crazy
you know because you're like in the
clouds you're in the mist it's like kind
of grim
and it's raining but then the summit is
like this totally wild
so like all those plants are incredibly
well adapted to this harsh environment
and they're really high rates of
carnivory like plants that eat things
because they're basically no soil one of
the books i read said that
described it as a rain desert like you
think of a desert normally as having
lots of soil but no water and there you
have infinite water but no soil
because it's a stone surface that's
getting rained on so much that it washes
all the soil away oh wow
so for any of the vegetation that live
there they basically all have different
strategies where they're rooted straight
to the stone
and then they they eat you know they eat
uh bugs and things that you know they
eat
insects or they eat other plants or they
you know they
lots of plants that grow on plants and
it's just like a whole crazy
web of life that's like really different
than what you expect it's weird because
it's so abundant
yeah it's got it's an unusual form of
life but it's everywhere
yeah like that's so rich and green like
you'd have
yeah though actually i bet if in that
photo if you'd pan the photo a bit to
the side there'd be like big expanses of
bear rock
because the summit's like yeah they're
little pastures and things it's almost
like alpine meadows if you go into the
mountains and
in the northern hemisphere um there'll
be like high tundras and things where
it's like yeah it feels really lush but
then there's also a lot of exposed rock
because when the sun comes out you know
you're at seven to nine thousand feet in
the tropics so it's
really intense uv exposure and it dries
things out instantly so it's a really
hard
hard climatic conditions for life wow
that's wild
yeah and so these uh organisms these
creatures that live up there
they're closely resembling creatures
that live in africa
and so that was part of what you're
studying yeah so we were with this
biologist who was trying to do an
elevational transect of
of the river basin that we were in so
basically starting from the rainforest
where the frogs are pretty well known
and then going up through the cloud
forest which is kind of as you gain
elevation to the actual wall
and then the species all change as you
gain elevation which is kind of normal
and then the things on the summit of the
tapuis on the summit of the
the stone island are completely
different again and so he was basically
doing research on
how how the different species you know
basically what the deal is
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience